how's it going breath my name is Pierre
PI and welcome back to the next episode
up to the moon the last episode we found
out so many things in the last one don't
you've got to watch the last one if you
watch this one
anyway River what's up this is all your
fault that's a bit cruel why am I alone
here I don't even remember yes oh I
remember now this is when he wanted to
go out with her I'm doing this for you
you artificially generated bastard well
I wasn't really his fault
I mean none of this should have happened
if Joey didn't get run over by that car
up he's walking turn around now I know
what you're planning to do I know that
you know yeah well I know that you know
that I know genius doctor was look at
our contract look our countries to send
in to the moon and the only way for that
to happen is if Johnny's motivated
elusive but if it means removing River
then what's the Papa then the reason why
he even wants that society you can
remove River
I know but we're legally bound to the
contract is specifically [ __ ] the
contract I didn't take this job to make
it miserable Eva I don't know about you
but I found out to help the freakin
geezer die happy me too and I like this
job but if we directly go against our
legal obligations we'd been for court
hearings will appeal we know that Johnny
be happy to not go tournament Johnny
would be happy
a lot of the alternate life tangents
Neil we are not here to play God a job
is to give him what he signed Paul well
we happen to know what he wants better
than he wouldn't exactly you're look I'm
only really risking losing it because
in her and what do you mean risk you're
removing her and besides I will make up
for it
make up for it how what is that we're
running out of time don't do it girl
just trust me I'm not trusting her says
you want to push me off the [ __ ]
lighthouse but what in the hell did you
just what is she doing
freaking light data abusing your powers
if my controls entirely Eva but booby
traps really ever just trying to buy
some time
gee thanks for telling me to move oh
really thank you for telling me this now
I only play the game for like four hours
but thank you for telling me how to move
at it oh yeah I'm up those are some
expensive pieces of equipment you're
causing seriously just stay put wait
until I'm good I'll piss off that's not
my role let's time I get is it up here
hmm this beautiful painting well it's
not here look don't make me exit this
whole thing and unplug you would you
really risk distorting his memory as
they are to stop trying to place this
one take on yeah not again or come and
find me at the end of the hall
fine it's creepy
what how are those I doesn't matter
Oh zombies zombies you got to be
freaking this is a game to even deal not
they aren't just zombie Eva's there's
zombies bunch of course ha don't come
any closer I'm armed with press it V is
the only key word to shoot dial L [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] check check check check
I can shoot cactuses [ __ ] off I have
cactuses
this is plants vs. zombies I get the
reference ah [ __ ] off platypuses [ __ ]
off bladder peasant Peppa Peppa well
those things are good for something
after I die zombie ass [ __ ] off Wow Wow
holy Sh out some peanut stop this
nonsense no this is so annoying
yes baby yes baby sexist sexist drop it
how the hell I got this I got this
but then I just go here
what the hell is going on you kidding me
stop yeah so weird I can shoot up come
on double zombies [ __ ] come on stop
shoot cactuses all day now long I can't
go there what I'm trapped now oh no I
know this whole thing is just Luke
oh really check this long to realize
well what oh [ __ ] this
what is he doing whoa huh you find a
loophole it's mushy cactuses what that
okay oh my god oh my god what does this
go when I am
I can't shoot cactuses anymore this
sucks
Eva what happened what sorry Eva what
did she do
how could she just remove River like
that what does he want what else
billions of lighthouses stuck at the far
end of the sky now the whole construct
semester the hell is this everything is
messed up it's freaking bunnies well
okay thank you I got this now
thank you for that game what do you want
bunny
what the hell his fetish River she won't
be alone anymore pickled olives this
night huh what I just I just don't want
to be an around typical kid in Co
typical paper hipster John what is it
like just the responsibility that's buzz
what really confused right now really
confused right now
what is this I'd help you understand it
hi this is here I don't know why risk
dying I don't know ha ow [ __ ] horses
I didn't pick that it scared me okay
bunny ah
shouts I it's more really
Emperor's New Clothes my hans-christian
medicine
he's a Danish fella I think pretty much
the only good thing Danish people I'm
just kidding
hello wait don't go I'm Johnny what's
your name I don't know your spot oh I'm
sorry I didn't mean to hug this place
all by myself
the memories are all shrewder looted
what is going on here like it was a long
time ago there's no dead a time Johnny
what enough is enough
I'm Gollum Ramsey stop this ha ha what
happened
Oh Neil Morpheus what oh it's Eva you
idiot no [ __ ]
we're the only ones hearing got Davin I
thought it was Morpheus ever again
listen whatever you're doing stop it you
might not know what Johnny wants but we
know what he doesn't want and what he
doesn't want is exactly what you're
accelerating it's already done Neil no
why don't you come out now [ __ ] is her
problem it's better be good
she better not delete him car whatever
okay is the art class and this is why
River is who is that where's she going
with what this is not correct what did
you do to her relax she's merely going
elsewhere so she's not there when he
comes is that it what you know it's one
thing to save my control to feed me some
olives but this is way out of line I'm
sorry this just won't go anywhere if you
keep on resetting the memory at this
point this is the only way I'm asking
you to trust me
so please just calm down and wait here
then just pull the trigger already what
are you doing there just one last thing
I needed to poseur there's no need to
visualise the door what what's with all
the melodrama Neil why are you fighting
so hard for this I don't know Neil
forget it there's no time
well everything's be all right man just
turn around okay okay
hey hey why did Shh see she's not here
now we can't go through the movies if
she's not hello what what what
sorry kid
it's already started
you can't do that
come on we're gonna hug all the good
tables they're all the same
geesh no Joe is right the ones be the
kitchen smell battery totally and all of
the refills are just steps away Joe is
alive
yeah Hollis I guess that's the only way
to make him not rid of his memory he's
alive saving him Justin testify you can
always find another river yeah no but
he'll only have one brother come on
we're in the way no no
short steps deep breath
everything has alright
chin up
I can't step into the spotlight
she said I'm sad somehow without any
were I just stood there searching for an
answer when this world is
I'll ask you to fly away with me
they empty from the sky but I told mine
if you're with me
everything's all
ah
why do my words always was there meaning
what I feel what I say there's such a
rift between them he said I can't really
seem to read you I just stood there
never know what I should do when this
world is no the moon is all sea
I'll ask you to fly away with me
stars all fall down the empty from the
sky
but I don't mind if you are with me and
everything
if you're with me and everything
you
what is going on here he's going to the
moon
oh that's it he's going really come on
No
and I'm gonna have to end this episode
here but I can favorite if you enjoyed
it's kind of come up right today I'll
see you in the final episode up to the
moon thank you